hey guys I think so recently I watched
this video from graphic story which is a
channel that I absolutely love they
featured a sushi chef that apparently
does one of the biggest sushis in Japan
pretty incredible and I really want to
try making one technically I could ask
Elvan to do it but that requires time
and patience that I don't have and so
I'm gonna try and make it happen the
only thing is I don't really have the
resources to do it but there's this
place called Roland who actually reached
out to say that they can actually do it
with me and not only that but they are
trying to break the world record for
making the biggest nigiri in the world
and so of course I said yes and so
that's where I'm heading over I have my
equipment here tada tada we're gonna
head over to their store and hopefully
make this happen
we finally made it here to roll it I'm
so excited to finally make this happen
I've been wanting to eat this I know
that's not the focus but I've been
wanting to make a giant aguirre and also
eat it what made you want to do this
it's our first birthday we've just
passed one year so we wanted to do
something that was exciting and also
memorable we do certainly Gary's here so
we wanted to try the the biggest nigiri
we possibly could I feel like a lot of
people who don't really know what nigiri
is I usually think it's just sushi what
is the difference
sushi is just kind of the broad category
and the gear is one of the things inside
us and the Giri is what people normally
think of as the traditional classic
sushi it's the little piece of rice with
a piece of fish on top fish rice vinegar
what are the exact quantities we're
talking about today because I know we're
doing like xx x XL and we've got three
really live sides of Salmons six massive
pots of rice cooked our few litres of
sushi vinegar ready to go it aiming for
some like at least 50 something pounds
we'll see how we go man fifty something
pounds that's the max I could carry at
the gym you know that you know that you
can go today is gonna be a workout I
know we're trying to break a record here
today what was the previous record we
know the largest Maki roll ever made was
around 13 pounds 13 pounds so 13 pounds
and you're saying we're making 50 and
we're trying go 50 yeah there's no
existing record so we're just gonna try
and be number one and try and make it as
big as we possibly can have some fun
with it yeah amazing okay let's get
started so we are going to start with
the rice first because that takes a long
time to cook I have 80 pounds of rice
here that we are apparently going to
cook olive all right I'm gonna yo I
can't carry it maybe for like two
seconds hold on this is not even all
that rice we're making but you see how
big this tub is right
this is the amount of rice I make for
dinner and also like for lunch the next
day this is for two meals so this is
gonna be pretty big to rice cookers
recipes we're gonna put three of these
jugs in each other okay wait but we only
have two rice cookers and we're supposed
to cook all of this yeah so how many
hours well luckily we started
[Music]
alright I'm gonna wash rice nothing hard
I do this every day it's just now this
is a lot more rice than I'm used to
three times I'm supposed to watch it for
three times in toto okay second time I
can already feel my arms turning a lot
clearer now three jugs of water so I'm
gonna put six rice cooker one is done
great alright I'm gonna take this fish
out oh my god
whoo-hoo this is seven pounds of fish
this is like a whole salmon this is
literally the whole salmon right will I
have
my arms hurt take the fins off the bone
am it skin off and break it down got it
is a big fish I'm petting the fish
awkward huh we have this giant jug again
this much vinegar has to go in one rice
pot and we're making six rice pots which
means we need three litres of vinegar
that's a lot of vinegar which is why we
have this hold on I can't even I can't
even this is how much
okay maybe not all of it but we're
starting with six go big or go home
Alvin don't at me you want to see the
paddle I have you wanna see the right
paddle it's so good I need this at home
I love this our giant tub of rice I'm
just gonna start mixing this together
I'm doing a great job okay conformation
I could just make tiny things not big
things I thought we're only using one
piece of salmon but apparently we're
using first step make the base shape of
the nigiri which is like an oval our
rice ball has to be big enough I can't
even carry this I don't know why I tried
[Music]
why am I out of breath I'm out of breath
you guys so we have the rice ball done
and we're gonna put the salmon on foot
because we're gonna divide this up later
we're gonna put like a cling wrap just
to make it easier for sharing later
we're also gonna have to support sticks
because it's a it's a giant nigiri
highest honor of putting the first piece
on I did not debone this orgy skin this
because I am not qualified to do it
final piece this is it y'all watch me
drop it on the floor
[Music]
oh my god wow that's so big oh my god
gonna do some measuring because I really
want to know I mean it looks huge but I
want to know exactly how big it is so I
have a measuring width is roughly 15
inches that's huge
Blaine's is 22 inches height is 9 inches
how many times the size of this hundred
these six points six one hundred twenty
six point two minus 157 is sixty nine
point two
that's like 70 pounds this is 70 pounds
did it Gavin was there for moral support
so we're gonna give this away what gotta
get a lot of taste first you see you
know QC my first okay no second my
second camera here it is this is really
fun I can say I made the biggest nigiri
in the world I can say that I ate the
biggest nigiri in the world thanks you
guys so much fun I'm gonna go eat more
sushi
[Music]